这是一个特别适合创业的时代
尤其是普通人
我认为普通人就应该在这个时代创业
我这么说肯定会有很认反对
说确认创业的人不是傻就是坏
还有很认识创业的镜头就是复在
对吧
我不怕得罪凡是这么认为的人
你的认知都极低
而且在生活中没有什么创业
你不信你对照一下
对吧
我不怕得罪你
我为什么会这么说呢
我们之所以认为普通人不是和创业
首先低个原因
就是普通人没有设错的成本
哪钱都拿不出来
这是事实
去年的时候有一个朋友小意过
在吃博裂说过了
对吧
然后做了一块AI的产品
一上来就获得得很好的结果
我当然问他无论这个项目投了多少钱
脱头400万
有多少人能拿出4万
400万都拿不出来
对吧
就很多人没有试错的能力
这是原因之一
但是各位
我们这边有输过
你先别否认他
我后面会讲
如果是可以做到的
如果你创业不需要什么成本
我的成本级低的话
有会怎么样呢
以后我会解释
然后两家二个
很认说创业不动人不适合创业
对吧
要创业的镜头是复杉
为什么
因为很多手你投了大量的时间
而成本
然后资金而人卖
对吧
但是东西出来以后
上市了之后
没有人卖
就牵了一批股在
一面投入没有产出嘛
对不对
但是这里边我有说一个主话
如果你的这个产品
在没有做之前
已经有大量的腐费的用过了
那又会怎么样呢
反正说这两个如果
就做梦养
我告诉你
这是可以做到的
创业是有防法的
和学习学习也是有防法的
有防法和媒方法的人
这个差别特别大
那今天给大家介绍一个方法
叫A.C.T.
我先简单说字面一次
然后给大家觉得实际的例子
什么是A就是用户
就是你在创业之前
先想就是你的用户是谁
别投钱一分钱都不投
创业之前先想
你的用户是谁
他有什么样的问题
大家什么场景下
遇到什么的问题
你可以怎么帮他解决
但一分钱都投
只想这个用户是谁
就是A
第二个部分的方法就得C
主要这里边有个重点
这个重点是什么呢
就是C的意思是钩通
先和用户钩通
什么意思呢
各位假设
你戴创业之前
什么你要投入很多时间
经历人力
最晚一个产品做出来吗
好现在各位
你的产品没做出来
但是你想你的产品做出来的
所以随便你的产品已经做出来的
现在产品已经有了
OK了
就查报市场推广了
你是不是在推广
对不对
各位
这个是个关键里
帮我过来
别把产品做完了
都投入了在推广
而是先推广
再做
或者是同时做
终于这里边有很重要的话
这都是什么呢
既然故事就是你的策略
你先把这个故事讲出来
产品还不一种做出来呢
但是呢
来获取用户的反馈
如果用户有反馈
太好了
如果用户没反馈
你还没做呢
各位能理由于是吗
就两个小例子
一个小例子叫招报
打去查
这个人在开始的时候
根本就没做
产品的产品干嘛的时候
就是运寸出吧
以前在处裁的时候
经常拿着纠款什么呢
他竟然会忘带
他又想要这个云寸出就好了
他有没有做这个产品呢
没做这个产品
他就直接拍了
拿紫贴了一个视频
假的故事放到网上了
几个好准夺问的
然后因为问的人多
最后他做了这么一款产品
和用户一块做这个产品
这个这个创业故事是有的
大家可以去去找一下
我在给大家几个小例子
就是我写的那个
假之心法那边说
不是先写完了
我再去推广
反而是一开始我就想
有一个什么样的东西
我觉得这个支持
对很多人是有帮助的
我先把它写出来
然后很多人就没反映
没反映出面什么
人们根本不需要这个支持
对了有些支持的话
一个人们反映特别强烈
我知道二人们需要的是这样一个东西
所以很多的想法
在我之前已经测试过了
然后呢
最后我这边说
传说是一个更完整的这么一个版本
所以我的这个产品刚出来的时候
就卖了特别的好
就各大排行网上
都都很好
这叫C叫
叫什么呢
就叫他顾通
就是先把用户活的
然后在考虑产品的时候
可以同时做
让用户帮助引作
被刀几个会不会会更强弃的
然后听着什么
听就是出发
出打
你在什么情况下
出打用户呢
对吧
你是在网站啊
共同号是视频平台啊
还是文本啊什么
你这个你看
我给大家举个通所在的例子
就明白了
假设你是个情小子
你可能就是个情小子
对了
你创业吗
不情小子
对吧
你喜欢一个姑娘
你想追这个姑娘
首先第一个
你是不是要了解这个姑娘
你连姑娘都不了解
对啊
喜欢吃什么
什么地方的人
他有什么的新鲁特征
生活中有什么的场景
你都不了解
你去追着姑娘
你传统吗
对对
所以这个
主角的A
第二个的话呢
就是你要和人家姑娘
共同
你要不兴趣
共同的建立联系
然后你越来越
然后也他他越来越
然后建立
你们可能关系就更好
对吧
雖然你这个情小子
但你可以让人
你可以说
请求一个机会
对吧
我很喜欢你
你们能给我一个机会
我没有要求别的
我只希望你给我一个机会
虽然我现在很求我
现在什么都没有
但是半年或者一年以后
我要购物天一个
什么什么东西
那么能给我一个机会
他我一点一点
正面给你看
可不可以
这就是谁呀
不断的包通和角流
我们购通交流越多
我们的年线就越大
对吧
那什么是什么是替呢
就是你一去怎么
喝哪儿去喝
就姑娘沟通和交流
姑娘天天去
突出管看书
你天地跑游易行就找姑娘的
不可能人都不去
对不对
所以用活在哪儿
你就那哪儿就要ACT
ACT
所以我给大家一个叫建议
就是ACT
先行
然后紧接了更长
MVP
为什么我说
现在是特别适合
创业的时代呢
因为我们创业两个很重要的东西
一个是购建
你再有东西和人交官呢
对吧
另外一个什么另外一个这个营修
购务建是什么
就是现在
我们购务建一款产品的成本基地
A.I.出来的
你看
我前两天昨天直播的时候说了个例子
比如说我们那个卡路里
我不怕吗
对吧
我看一个卡路
算一个卡路里
把拍照
一个弹刀
一个树菜
把告诉你
躲卡路里
以前用软件实现
这个需要花很多成本的
现在用A.I.
实现其实
份分钟的事
是不是这样有落击
昨天晚上我还做的个
直播还几个例子
比如说有些听书的软件
硬眼会员多少钱
然后他组织了好多好多人
把一本书给独胞
然后给你捏出来
把听书是这样的吧
当然现在用A.I.I.就完成
各位你会发现
可以很快的把一本书独胞
然后有语音给你打算说
不是不刺语那个产品
等等成本基地
说是A.I.I.让这个成本变的基地
你完全在可以获得用户的
这个需求之后
然后你快速度用极的成本
给用户一个功能
然后不断的根据用户的短快
不断的有化
不断的细化
刚开始可以免费啊
听吧
甚至我可以搞很多活动啊
这就是
就是为什么我说
现在才被适合创的原因
就是A.I.I.
人工就能够
够件的方面的成本基地
另外就是户来吧
户连网上以获得
用户的成本变成基地
就你以前干嘛
你还在给老板搬工区
打动老板
然后老板给你个机会
今天不是今天
在户来网上这样一个模式
你给别人分享价值
别人看到你有价值
就会否落你
对吧
可能一百个人看到的东西
可能只有两三个人关注你
但他是不是有机会呢
你你你你你你
你这成本很低啊
你想我现在有三百多万分次
我的成本就什么
就不知道不知道不知道不知道不知道不知道
不知道不知道不知道
成本是不是很低啊
反正我平时要学习呢
所以户连网
就是一个很好的
或去用户的方法
这是一个很好的
方法论
叫A.C.T.
加I.M.O.V.P
就我们为什么以前
就创业就让会否在啊
就让你投了大量的时间
人力啊
资源啊
资源这个东西
没人用
对吧
没有用户
昨天提到我来
A.C.T.
产品没有做之前
我先一份钱的头
我先想好用户是谁
然后再网上
和用户建立问题
狗通
鸟获得用户的需求
然后一定用人工
只能快速地提供一个人性
然后不断地去
喜欢